it's the gutfeld rule if you want to
make anything worse just add the media
they're like anchovy paste the one thing
we now know for certain is that politics
is superseding medicine here
when i watched i'm watching that car the
parade yesterday with him in the car
that was right out of a dictator's
playbook it's a karmic twist
because trump has deployed the politics
of sickness in this campaign
the president seemed to be flirting uh
with the coronavirus by not wearing a
mask and going to big rallies
i would never want to say that the
president is experiencing steroid
induced psychosis
but um it is certainly concerning to see
some of his actions today
his response has been homicidal
negligence he has failed to protect the
american people
is it worse than watergate so a
president gets sick
and they say i told you so cnn corners
the wet market on that
they hardly said much early on too busy
gorging on impeachment and now they arm
chair quarterback
as if wisdom is knowing what happened
after it happened
oh and that steroid induced psychosis so
now you're admitting that he never had
psychosis to begin with
how nice of you fact is everyone was
wrong on the virus at one time
or another even the experts especially
the experts the measure of a leader is
listening to advice and then doing
what's right
trump actually sent a boat to nyc and
they left it empty
he sent tons of ventilators to nyc he
sent money to everyone and shut down an
economy
he stopped travel even when dems called
him racist he stayed calm when others
wouldn't
but he also knew that as a leader he
must endure risk
to expect risk from others you go to
work so must he
why do you think the five came back to
studio f if we said go back to work we
should too
so don't indulge those looking for
scores to settle instead while the media
minds for misery encourage compassion
so what happens when a fearless
bombastic personality
has a health scare will he change
of course trump might be trump forever
but the scariest thing for never
trumpers is a healthy trump in a country
that prefers it
still a health shock can change people
for good look at me
i went through childbirth at an early
age and i haven't been the same since
dana so they sound the alarm the media
sounds the alarm that it's way worse
than you think right on friday and now
he's not at death's door so he must be a
murderer
he's out and about he's a murderer i
think that there's no doubt the white
house did not have a good
uh initial communications rollout on
this on saturday
and i think that the press office did as
best as they could but if they're going
to be cut out of the loop
then you can't expect them to do a good
job and i think that that was a real
disservice to
kaylee mcanini and her team and she
deserves better and i hope that they
demand better from the white house chief
of staff that was
no bueno no bueno no bueno no ever no
cultural appropriation here
not getting complete information or
information in the right way that you
want it does not mean that you can then
speculate
yes about the president's health it
doesn't work that way it's not like it's
like saying
oh um i know that the president's doctor
is saying this but my aunt posted
something on facebook that she saw on
wmd
and that must be something that we
should really take seriously uh going
forward so
uh yeah there was a i could you're
watching that montage i can see why some
people watch fox all day long
i know because we are real where is i i
jesse i imagine like at cnn they have
those morning board meetings
and they have a machine that that gauges
what is the most bizarre deranged theory
and then when that goes in the red zone
they go put that in the lineup
psychosis there were a lot of scandals
and conspiracies over the weekend greg
i had uh body doubles we were told he
said
staged photo ops russian intelligence
officers were
in walter reed operating on the
president yeah
we heard about um the secret service
gate
after the media watched video of covid
crowds screaming in the faces
of law enforcement officers all summer
all of a sudden they cared
about law enforcement driving in a car
with all the ppe and the mass
the guys probably had already gotten
kovid or they volunteered which were the
reports
i don't know greg i think now the
president is invincible just by the way
the media has set
expectations so low this thing was
supposed to be a death sentence
and he's walking out of wall to read
three days later
better than ever i just don't think they
played this right
what do you think juan he's walking out
of wall three better than ever
i'm glad you're not mine he's been
released okay i don't think he looks
i look i just wish the world i wish the
best for him but i gotta say
everybody including his own doctor says
we got to keep an
eye on him going back to the white house
where they've got tremendous medical
because it's not like you or me going
home i'm just saying if you look at the
coverage they look like
crypt keepers over the weekend i don't
think so i think that you've got a
situation
and greg this speaks to your monologue i
think this is an example of what about
well somebody else made a mistake once
and so he made a mistake and he's just
trying to be optimistic the reality is
he downplayed this virus all along by
his own admission that's not me speaking
that's him on tape to woodward sees i'm
going to downplay this right
okay he then downplays it he doesn't
follow the science rules he ignores says
science uh
this scientist says that so much for uh
doctors
so much for doctor no he did not
obviously did not
oh and obviously not how do you know he
mocks joe biden he says oh what look at
that big mass
trump he mocks this guy and
again the example to the american people
is the mask
is political it's not a matter of
science it's not your best protection
if you're a trump supporter don't wear a
mask that's just absurd
i don't think the thing about it is he
didn't protect us
the american people he didn't protect
his staff
you should have heard you should have
heard my phone secret service people
over the weekend
bizarre gone off that he is putting them
at risk
so that he can have a secret service on
you oh yeah let me just tell you
something they were calling you
not only that when you stop and think
about it just in terms of the absolute
numbers
you know four percent of the world
population here in america 25
of the coronavirus cases here that's
failure
that's an absolute failure
you haven't done the math they gotta you
gotta hold on and say wait a second
i hope this is not just about
appearances and spin
i hope that he's okay megan you don't
sound like you hope he's okay well i do
you know he's dancing he's on the ground
two minutes but i mean it's like what
john bolton said
john bolton said everything is about his
you know what the media
said for years he's a dictator he just
wants a power grab and you know what he
did
not act like a dictator he gave the
power to the governors
and local authorities to make decisions
about the different regions of this
country
because he understands that we're a
nation of great liberties and freedoms
and americans don't like being told what
to do so you leave it up to people it's
like wear a mask
but i'm not going to mandate it which
okay joe biden
right really quickly in terms of the
professional panic peddlers
in the media these people some of them
clearly over the weekend stood back and
said you know i've only got a
teaspoon of credibility left i've only
got a like a soup sand of integrity
so i'm flushing it all away now i'm
gonna leave this job and go sell
cans of seeds and bomb shelters for the
next apocalypse
i expect some of them they're so
well expletive that they'll be standing
in front of trump tower
any time now screaming shame shame and
anybody who's taking a selfie in front
of the building